tú bombardeas nosotros bombardeamos es
el mensaje del jefe de hezbollah para el
ejército israelí hasan nasralá afirmó
haber disparado cohetes contra israel el
viernes fue la respuesta a los ataques
recibidos por líbano el día anterior
joey a cualquier ataque aéreo israelí
contra el líbano irá inevitablemente
seguido de una respuesta pero se hará de
forma adecuada y proporcionada porque
queremos proteger al país
una declaración firme pero cautelosa
este jueves por primera vez en siete
años el ejército israelí golpeó suelo
libanés fue la respuesta a un cohete
disparado contra el estado hebreo el
martes 4 de agosto los atacantes todavía
no han reivindicado su autoría este
viernes hezbollah e israel- cruzaron
fuego fue en zonas deshabitadas sin
causar víctimas uno de los portavoces
del ejército israelí dijo que el país no
quiere una guerra real no está preparado
para lo que pueda pasar es casi palabra
por palabra lo que también dice el jefe
de hezbollah
no buscamos el conflicto y no queremos
ir a la guerra pero estamos preparados
el lanzamiento de cohetes no
reivindicado que provocó la reacción de
israel tuvo lugar el 4 de agosto el
mismo día del aniversario de la
explosión del puerto de beirut parte de
la población libanesa acusa a hezbollah
de estar involucrado en la tragedia un
hecho poco habitual tuvo lugar este
viernes un lanzacohetes utilizado por
hezbollah para disparar a israel fue
interceptado por ciudadanos libaneses
enojados que acusan a hezbollah de poner
en peligro a los ciudad
del líbano